mais j'en peux plus je parle exactement
comme j'en veux parler christiane ça
fait 20 ans qu'on habite ici ça fait 20
ans que tous les jours tous les jours
tous les jours on a des cars de juifs
avec des discours de judée cérémonie
juive des dés à l'image de bougies
je rembourse du juif panthères midi et
soir excuse moi un bouge un peu plus moi
ici je ne vais rien mais c'est pas une
raison pour monter le son du téléviseur
le concierge avait la voisine elle
partait au commissariat déposer une
plainte je te signale le col de pause
d'un dépôt de plainte
grand bien lui fasse moi aussi je vais
déposer plainte un contre à la base in
non contre les juifs
quand tous ces juifs qui me pourrissent
des clans mais moi comme si les juifs
étaient les seuls l'histoire de
l'humanité avoir souffert à seyssins
roger un risque d'y en sont les seuls
non je crois pas est ce que les juifs
ont le monopole de la souffrance j'ai
pour moi et quoi et les noirs les arabes
gitans les italiens les arménien à
l'ailé polak jo pas souffert eux ils
n'ont pas souffert des mois je n'ai pas
souffert mais tu as souffert de quoi
rougir
et souffert je vous fait d'eux des trous
ah bon je te dire une bêtise mais si ta
grand mère était juive ça fait quoi on
va dire qu'on pourra aussi tu voulais
aussi si malheureusement il est bien
juif c'était sa grand mère maternelle et
comme ça se transmet dans la mer ça se
transmet comme une maladie et qui a
décrété sa à doha et c'est pire encore
avec les lois de nuremberg que
d'ailleurs vous comptez remettre à
l'ordre du jour la main vers mon père ou
mère suffirait ça n'a pas de sens il
confirme par là on va parler je poursuis
des craintes et demi que je suis loin de
moi je suis noir facebook peut pas
devenir noir ou juif comme ça du jour au
lendemain moi je ne peux pas vous dire
je ne m'y connais pas bien mais juif
c'est très compliqué de devenir et ben
alors alors si c'est si difficile si
c'est si compliqué comment vous avez la
preuve que ta grand mère était juive à
son père s'appelait katzman mouvement et
sa mère était une fille seligman ils
sont morts tous les deux à auschwitz
plus rien ne va nous avons tout s'est
joué après des heures et des heures des
jours des semaines de réflexion j'en
suis arrivé à cette conclusion il faut
innover sortir des sentiers battus et
tenter des choses nouvelles des choses
fortes des choses radical je pense que
j'ai trouvé une solution
et pour cela j'ai besoin de tous
laissez moi s'il vous plaît allez
jusqu'au bout de mon idée je sais que
certains d'entre vous réagir ont
brutalement mais je vous en prie encore
une fois laissez moi aller jusqu'au bout
si on regarde bien la situation
on observe que seuls les juifs s'en
sortent
non laissez moi finir laissez moi finir
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
non seulement ils ont de l'argent mais
ils s'entraident ce que j'en déduis ce
que j'en déduis et que je propose est
très simple puisque les juifs sont
riches et qu'ils sont solidaires
devenons tous juifs